what was the Tipping Point was the
Tipping Point when he went to the
binance CEO and says hey uh uh I I need
you to you know why don't we partner up
and okay I need a billion dollars from
he said oh yeah we'll do the deal and
the last one no no we're not doing the
deal because even if we buy it it's just
not the interview that he did which was
fascinating by the way the CEO binance
so very impressed by that guy says no
we're not even touching him he says are
you concerned that you're losing a
company like FTX as a competitor he says
he's not a competitive you know this
business we're not competitors so what
was if you're saying last year they lost
three to four billion in a in a very
bullish Market what was the Tipping
Point all of a sudden hey we got to get
recently got away with this he's running
a private unregulated cut set of
companies right he had his private
holding company paper bird he had
Alameda a private company he had FTX a
private company no transparency no
disclosure if you were running a public
company you got to actually publish
audited financials every quarter and
make AK statements and you have adult
supervision you I have lawyers Bankers I
have two sets of lawyers two sets of
accountants you know an army of an army
of internal accountants external
accountants
Etc and if I just came on your show and
said hey I just wanted to announce that
microstrategy has 175 000 Bitcoin my
phone would start ringing by the lawyers
put that down they'd be like what are
you doing you're crazy and and you know
they would say it not just because it's
wrong they would say it because their
careers are on the line and they don't
want to spend 10 years in litigation
hell so there's a way that you run a
public company and there's a way you run
a regulated company and and on the other
hand Sam was his own regulator he could
make up his own rules he had he was
accountable to no one and if you have 10
billion dollars in the bank and then you
lose 4 billion
and you don't and the bank doesn't have
to disclose what is done with the money
you just go and give yourself a four
billion dollar loan secretly you know he
didn't tell anybody so they were able in
essence because they had so much power
as private unregular it's not just
unregulated it's one thing to be
unregulated it's unregulated and opaque
if you if you look at uh and poorly run
right there are some offshore businesses
tether binance that are that are not
regulated and they're not onshore in the
US they're not public but but by Common
wisdom they generally are viewed as
better run like adults adult supervision
because when people ask them to redeem
15 billion dollars they can do it right
I think that FTX three arrows you know
these companies that went bankrupt doe
Quan and Luna they were just really
poorly run opaque crypto organizations
and it was it was destined now that what
was the pen I think
like there was uh there was a summer a
simmering uh a simmering war going on
between the Bitcoin movement and the
crypto movement in DC and the Bitcoin
movement is Satoshi gave us ethical
money nobody controls it you have to pay
for it by burning energy or by buying it
with real cash and you can't corrupt it
you can't issue more it's capped at 21
million nobody gets to you know co-opt
it or use it in a useless fashion to
make themselves Rich okay that's Bitcoin
um the crypto world is you know well we
invented Solana to be better than
Bitcoin and we invented such and such
ftt to be cleaner than Bitcoin and don't
mind the fact that we gave 80 percent of
it to ourself right and that uh and that
we're going to dump the rest on the
general public and we're opaque about it
now that that uh war is going on on
Capitol Hill where the crypto Lobby is
lobbying for light or no regulation let
us basically issue these tokens and make
them Commodities and so we don't have
any Securities laws constraining us
The Regulators that understand better
like a guy like the chair of the SEC
would say look they're all Securities
you can't just let them trade as
Commodities that's the same as saying
anybody can issue their own equity and
and lie cheat and steal the general
public and that would threaten the
entire 100 trillion dollar Securities
Market
but you know Sam you know Sam was the
number two donor the Democratic party he
was the number three donor to the
Republican Party they've admitted to 200
million to 300 million in donations but
they might have donated hundreds of
millions more you're saying that he was
donating that much Republican we were
very familiar with how much he's donated
to the Democratic party he was I believe
number two but yeah he needs both sides
I tell you his daughter it's diabolical
we know that he was the number two donor
to the Democratic party and until about
a month ago that was the narrative and
then we found out that the chief
operating officer that worked for him
was the number three donor to the
Republican party and and that guy gave
25 million to the Republicans in the
last few weeks so not he himself not
himself because he is fully uh
supportive of what the Democratic
beliefs are look I mean he wanted to be
viewed as remember he said he was going
to give a billion dollars in the next
election cycle yeah he might have given
a billion in the last election cycle we
don't know but he wanted to be viewed as
the as the great uh Progressive Savior
and finance here so they gave they gave
hundreds of millions of dollars to
celebrities they give hundreds of
millions of dollars to academic
institutions hundreds millions of
dollars to politicians huge amounts of
money to journalists right why wouldn't
you keep in mind if I can generate 10
billion dollars in air token in order to
make a billion a year
all I got to do is take 10 million
dollars lever it up five to one lean on
the liquidity on my own exchange and the
price moves three or four bucks I get
two billion dollars more I made two you
know I made two billion in the year in
investment income and then I go and I
borrow one or two or three or four
billion in my margin account
right they had in that they were
counterfeiting money and then they were
using the counterfeit money to steal
other money or either to steal it from
their deposit or steal it from their
investors or steal it from creditors
then they were funneling that into the
political and the marketing process and
that's why you saw them on the Super
Bowl ad that's why the FTX Arena was
named after them that's why every
celebrity is getting sued right now so
what all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks right if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks right
here future looks bright here we got
them in white we got them in Black we
got them in red our black on black sold
out these are about to sell out if you
haven't ordered one yet we had a person
in Michigan but one then he bought three
then when those three people weren't in
the office they had to order 58 of them
because people wanted the future looks
bright hats especially during times like
this because ain't nobody's saying
future looks spread toward your future
looks bright hat click over here and to
Washington to our podcast click here
take care everybody
[Music]